- So I'm gonna talk about inference.
From more or less a quantum
field theory point of view,
I'm gonna attempt to, to
make it very accessible,
and I think one of the
real problems for physics
is that quantum field theory
is not accessible enough.
So I've spent the last 20 years
focused on renormalization,
but I'm not gonna talk about that at all.
There are three recent
articles that talk about,
I'm gonna have to speed up.
That talk about the relationship
between quantum mechanics
and classical mechanics
and about the measurement problem.
But they do so in terms of,
and underlying ideas about
quantum field theory,
and specifically as if it's
a noisy signal analysis formalism.
And I think that can make
contact with this workshop
in the sense that inference
and machine learning
can be thought of as
data analysis toolboxes.
So one can approach the relationship
between quantum mechanics
and classical mechanics
in so many different ways.
The way I've chosen to
do for the last few years
is partly through the
idea that no-go theorems
tell us that quantum
mechanics is more than,
in some sense, classical mechanics.
And so one approach following on from that
is to think that we
should try to construct
a more complete version
of classical mechanics.
Add to it instead of trying
to add to quantum mechanics
so that it's more like
classical mechanics.
And in the articles above,
I construct what I call CM+,
and that includes in the first instance,
measurement incompatibility.
So in algebraic terms, non-commutativity.
You can use the Poisson bracket.
If you are willing to
use it in its full power,
you can use the Poisson bracket
to construct a full algebra
or non-commutative algebra
of measurement operators,
measurement observables,
within classical mechanics.
It's sort of, it's been strawmanned,
classical mechanics being strawmanned,
so that you cannot use
these things just by fiat.
If you do do this, then the
next thing you need to do
is to introduce the idea, well,
is to recognize that quantum
noise and thermal noises
cannot be the same thing
within this new structure.
You need to find some
really solid difference,
and quantum field theory
actually has a solid difference.
Quantum noise within quantum field theory
can be thought of as just the
Lorentz invariant component,
the vacuum is Lorentz
invariant, and so it's noise,
insofar as you're willing to
accept that there's noise
there, is Lorentz invariant
And that, for me, as a field theorist,
implies that we should really think of CM+
as a field theory.
So a random field theory
would be a terminology
that can be used.
But I'm not going to include into this
analyticity, what I'm
gonna call analyticity,
which is a consequence of the
fact that quantum mechanics
rejects the positive
frequencies, which CM+ does not.
And I wanna keep them separate
because I want to be able to compare
CM+ with quantum mechanics,
quantum field theory,
and see what the differences are
and hence perhaps learn
something about both.
And indeed this projection
of positive frequency's
very similar to what you'll
find in signal analysis
where there is the idea
of an analytic signal
and a real signal essentially
as the positive frequency
and the not positive and
an unconstrained frequency.
Okay, so CM+ is a Hilbert space formalism
for noisy signal analysis.
And insofar as it is a
Hilbert space formalism,
it can describe experiments
equally well as quantum field theory.
And indeed, for the electromagnetic
field in particular,
not for all such things, we
can construct isomorphisms,
linear isomorphisms, between
quantum electromagnetism
and what I'm call CM+ electromagnetism.
So this is not quantization
because it is isomorphisms.
It's a much cleaner construction.
It's not a replacement for quantization,
but it is an alternative that I suggest
is useful to have in the toolbox.
It's not a panacea, it's
statistically non-local.
This is something that is
going to have consequences down the road
as we try to study what it might do.
Okay, so I submitted this
abstract to Priya five weeks ago
and I've struggled to keep to it.
Correlation's not equal to causality,
obviously, very naive sort of thing.
What do we have to add to it?
Causal modeling does add something to it.
Intervention in particular gives us
a means of talking about causality.
In mathematics and physics, however,
we have generalized
probability and contextuality,
which gives us similar
tools in a framework
that is essentially algebraic as a whole,
and in that sense, I feel
that it's more unified.
Obviously this is to people's
taste, to some extent.
And for machine learning,
we'll discover in the last four slides
whether or not I have
something interesting to say.
So again, there's so many
things you can pick out
from causal modeling.
The do-notation, so many
people pick out that,
well of course I should as well.
In any case, it seems connected to
the state preparation that
one has in quantum mechanics.
So we have required for a transformation
is more or less you take
a dial, you turn it to X,
there is your, I have willed it so.
You could have turned it to X1, X2, X3.
You didn't, you turned it to X.
So do X equals x is semantically different
in that sense from, it
happened that X equals x.
There was no will involved at all.
But mathematically, it's just the same.
Both of these constructions
can fit perfectly well into
as models of the Kolmogorov's Axioms.
So we have experimental protocols
decree what will be done
by the experimenter.
The experiment typically is not free.
There is a design of
the experiment that says
you will choose random numbers.
If you choose all zeros,
then you will have to
do the experiment again.
We can transform any aspect
of an experimental apparatus
by having enough dials, each
one of which is connected
to the internals of the
apparatus so that things happen.
And afterwards, however,
there's just data in computer memory.
That is what you are going to use.
You're gonna apply any
algorithm that works.
And you've done multiple interventions
and you keep track of what
interventions you've done
to obtain that data.
So from a data analysis perspective,
one thing we obviously do is
construct relative frequencies.
And for that, we just construct a number
between zero one, but a rational number,
and we can add those, as long
as we don't double count,
to get a new relative frequency.
We can add many of them,
so long as we don't double
count or omit anything,
we'll get the real number one.
And well, we have to keep
track of double counting
and omission in one way or another.
So historically, the relative frequencies
came out of the 19th century.
The Kolmogorov's Axioms
followed that mathematics.
And if it hadn't, we'd be talking about
someone else's axioms, I suggest.
And then once we had
the Kolmogorov's Axioms,
then we construct models for those
in terms of expected values
for the relative frequencies,
which are now real numbers
instead of rational numbers, perhaps.
We can talk about different semantics.
So something like propensities.
We can talk about the do semantics.
And we can also construct
linear algebraic models
for the Kolmogorov's Axioms.
So when we construct a, nope, wrong thing,
I've just gone forward a
line that I didn't intend to,
but I won't go back.
So when we construct for frequencies,
then we hope that those
will come turn out to be
the same as what we had from a theory
that we had written down.
Algebraically, we could use compatible,
so commutative operators,
to construct this.
Also gives us a positive number,
and so by choosing the right state
and the right projection operators,
we can make this be the same as this.
But also we can, if we
want to, use arbitrary,
so long as the spectrum of the operator,
no, arbitrary operators at Y and X,
that give us the same numbers as this,
but using non-commutative operators.
And this, in fact, is the mathematics
of the collapse of the wave function,
but just used to construct
a conditional probability,
or indeed of the top line,
just joint probability.
So we have generalized probability
gives us ways to interpolate
between different contexts.
So if we do find many
more through frequencies
and we find in many different contexts,
we place a new context
relative to an earlier context,
then we can compute expected values
for the new relative frequencies.
And that's what we get out of
the linear algebra of quantum
mechanics in particular.
Incompatibility is a
way of placing context
as non-trivial transformations
of other contexts.
For quantum mechanics, we
can do that straightforwardly
because we can generate
transformations instantly
just by using any omission operator.
For CM+ it's a little more difficult,
because we only have commutative algebra,
but we can use the Poisson bracket
to construct the transformation algebra,
direct transformation
algebra, and then we can use,
so long as we don't strawman ourselves
to construct just the same algebra
as we have from quantum mechanics,
or quantum field theory, in fact.
So I'm gonna talk about
the Bell inequalities,
with apologies, but entirely
from a field theoretic
point of view.
This is an experiment from the 1995.
This is page 60 from
Gregor Weihs's thesis.
It's a really nice diagram
from my point of view,
partly because up here, no, can't,
I do have to go back from now on.
Up here, he talks about a pump.
He pumps the electromagnetic
field, as I will say.
He doesn't shovel particles in,
he pumps the electromagnetic field.
Then he also is extremely clear
about what he's gonna store.
He's gonna store the time
at which events happen.
No particles in this at
all, in this description.
It's not that you can't
have a particle description,
but if you do, then you're gonna have
quite a compromised idea of
a particle in order to do so.
But for a field theory point of view,
our idea of pumping a noisy field,
it's actually perfectly
straightforward for me.
So he also, again, with the wrong key.
So he also stores which of
these avalanche photodiodes
actually had the signal
went from some low end.
I have a beautifully shaky hand,
which is exactly the shaky
as the display there.
And when an event happens,
then that's the time
which Gregor stores.
And at the same time, he also stores
the random bit generated value
that has set the
electro-optic modulator here,
which is changing the polarization
on a sort of megahertz scale
so that we can say
something about causality.
It needs to be that fast in order for this
to be a good test of that.
On the other hand, this
experiment is much simpler
than the 2016 experiments.
And so I don't want to
use that for display.
So here's the actual data,
my computation of this.
This is 15,000 event, oh again.
15,000 events.
And you can see the coincidence there.
Within about one nanosecond,
all of these 15,000 events total across,
all of these plus or
minus three nanoseconds.
And indeed you can see
that many of the events
are green and yellow in the
color scheme I've used here,
where the red is the diagonal,
the blue is the lower diagonal,
and the yellow and the green
are the other two diagonals.
And that green and yellow
is actually signifies
the violation of inequalities.
If you turn that diagram on its side,
you slice it a hundred times in this way,
you can compute a histogram that counts
each of the 16 different types of events.
You can add up those numbers,
and then you can put that into
by now completely standard calculation
of a violation of the Bell inequalities.
So all we've done here is we have
a completely classical set of data.
We've applied a completely
classical algorithm,
and out of that we've got
a number at which point,
classical particle physics
says, no, this is not any good.
We cannot have this.
So what I'm gonna point to you
is that in quantum mechanics,
we actually use measurement
incompatibility,
the non-commutativity of
the algebra of measurements
to model the violation
of Bell inequalities.
And this is something
you find in literature
since about 1980.
In classic mechanics as usual,
we don't have measurement incompatibility.
We've strawmanned ourselves,
so we're not allowed to do it.
One response to this is, well,
you can read what comes next as well,
is we can say that classical mechanics
is computationally incomplete.
Quantum mechanics is more
that classical mechanics.
So we can use the Poisson bracket
to add measurement incompatibility
into classical mechanics, giving us CM+,
so it's computationally as
complete as quantum field theory.
It's just a more effective thing
than classical mechanics itself.
So I've focused on non-commutativity.
There's clearly a whole pile of literature
about nonlocality.
For quantum fields,
microcausality asserts that
locality is closely associated
with measurement incompatibility.
And indeed, there's a version of that
which is called holo duality,
which really makes it identical.
Quantum fields are, however,
are much less like
classical particle physics
than they are like the heat equation
or any kind of non-equilibrium
thermodynamics.
So those kinds of equate things
do depend on the boundary conditions.
Once you've set the boundary conditions,
the whole system will equilibriate
to the boundary conditions.
So completely different
from what one expects
for a particle physics intuition.
And indeed, temperature
measurements in classical,
what effectively is CM+
as far as I'm concerned,
are just sized for measurements
in quantum field theory,
approximately local, but
they are not point-like.
This is something that is standard
in the more mathematical
literature on quantum field theory.
So if you're willing to go with me
on the idea that quantum field theory
can be thought of usefully
as a noisy signal analysis formalism,
then I suggest that we do
introduce measurements.
This is a measurement theory
because quantum mechanics
is a measurement theory,
and indeed, quantum field theory is about
a measurement operator
of value distribution,
which we use to construct
a measurement operator,
which I'm gonna index with something
which I'm gonna label f,
and I'm going to click
through to the next slide
too soon again.
Where those two, in
fact, I'm gonna go back
so that I don't distract myself.
Where the functions f and g,
they're called test functions
in the mathematical literature,
they're called window functions,
much more graphically,
in the signal analysis literature.
These also can be thought
of as the readme functions.
If you're a computer programmer,
you need to know how you got
the data in computer memory
that the measurement gave you.
So those describe where and
when and how big, what shape,
and anything else the
experiment is gonna need,
strictly speaking ought
to be in that description.
So, now formally, in quantum field theory,
an f measurement and a g measurement,
which is how I term them,
are if those are space-like
or causally separated,
then they're compatible operators,
in which case this expression,
get the right button,
is a correlation coefficient.
It's just as you'd expect
in classical statistics,
classical probability theory.
But if they are time-like
or light-like separated,
then they are incompatible,
and this construction has
an imaginary component,
which I suggest we can
think of as a bookkeeping
from an engineering point of view,
a bookkeeping for the
consequences of quantum noise
for this particular pair of measurements.
Now, we do have to work
with causal correlations
at time-like separation.
We have to have models for that.
What we use for that is the
collapse of the wave function.
It's just a mathematics for
constructing a joint probability
for constructing correlation coefficients.
This is obviously a way of, well,
I term it in the third of the papers,
I decided at the top,
are a construction of
a joint probability construction.
And this is a way of rethinking
the measurement problem,
I find, and some people
have also thought so.
So what I think quantum field
theory does is it, oh, sorry.
For this CM+ electromagnetism,
it's empirically equivalent to,
because it's isomorphic to
quantum electromagnetism,
the f measurement and the g measurement
are always compatible.
So you haven't got the
quantum field theory yet,
but you use the Poisson bracket
to introduce the transformation algebra
and use it in a general enough way
that it gives you all of the operators
you'd expect in quantum field theory.
And you can do it, it's isomorphic.
It's published, anyway.
And so finally, I think
we can think of this
as quantum field theory
folding into the formalism,
just the quantum noise
aspect of causality.
This is something that's reasonable to do,
but it's also something you
don't necessarily have to do.
You could make a conventional
choice of using CM+EM,
if that's more helpful,
if it's good to keep
your quantum noise separate.
Okay, so six months ago,
because of machine learning
and causal modeling,
and because of Franke, damn it,
I really started to wonder whether
physics really needs to be
about more than probability.
Because machine learning, it seemed to me,
doesn't necessarily try to classify data
into reference classes.
It doesn't necessarily count anything.
So machine learning algorithm
just takes a data item
in its initial state
and constructs a state after that,
and that need not be any kind of linearity
or guided by probability distribution,
probability theory at all.
So relative frequency,
just not part of it,
this whole thing.
And on the other hand, there are certainly
generative large language models
typically are constrained to
be consistent with probability,
and it makes them much
more understandable,
and that's part, I think,
of why people have adopted
an interest in them,
because they feel that it can
be understood at some level.
So if an algorithm is
consistent with probability,
I suppose we might call it
Bayesian machine learning
because it does try to keep,
does make it more understandable.
But I do wonder whether it's better,
it is might be better to
keep very clear in one's mind
as to whether you want to go
that way or the other way.
I'm not saying you shouldn't
go one way or the other,
just it is something to keep in mind.
Okay, so I'm gonna go back for a moment
to the data we had before.
This is out a hundred nanoseconds each way
instead of three nanoseconds each way.
You can see that in the center
is the narrow coincidences,
beautifully engineered, I
mean, getting that to work.
Years of research, years of
constructing the experiment.
But you can see there's also
this other narrower, sorry,
broader band at roundabout
plus or minus 29 nanoseconds.
Gregor didn't know that was there.
If he had, he would've
had to spend an extra,
well, he might have taken a
day to realize what it was,
but he might have spent two years more
figuring out what the
hell was causing that.
Excuse my French.
So there's something about
debugging the apparatus
that would have required
him to go back in and say,
"What could be causing this problem?
What do I have to change
to make the problem smaller or larger?
If I can figure out how to make it larger,
I probably can just say, ah,
change the direction somehow."
This is something that you really,
debugging is very causal in this sense.
But also I'm saying it can
be addressed classically,
so long as you're willing to
put into this Planck's constant
very seriously and model it as a classical
Lorentz invariant noise.
Mathematically, isomorphisms
really make me think, like,
I don't have to do the same
thing for every experiment.
I can just say isomorphism
to you. (chuckles)
Of course there will be
exceptions, I have no doubt.
And there's another thing
that I would like to know
about this experiment,
and that is this 10-second period
that he collected data for.
Yes, lots of data, beautiful.
It's practically at equilibrium,
in the sense of it being
timeless translation in variant
in a cause-grained way.
It's not translation in variant.
If you just look at this
particular event here,
because that is a signal going bang.
Not in equilibrium at fine grade scale.
But this is still thermodynamics.
A gas doesn't have equilibrium
at the 10 to minus 9 meter scale.
So here you turn on the power,
there are very few
events at the beginning.
You think yourself, well,
what will happen here?
Will the violation of
Bell inequality precede
the events actually happening, somehow?
Will it happen later?
How fast will it be?
Will this time period,
from lots of events to lots
of events, coincidences,
and green and yellow,
will that be enough time
for light to go backwards
and forwards 50 times?
Or will it be enough time for the light
to go back and forwards 0.1 times?
There's a big difference
between those two things.
Huge difference.
And yet this doesn't probe that at all.
Again, you need to have the
same apparatus as he's got,
or something very similar.
And you need to be probing
this aspect of this.
Now, I've just talked about
this turning on the power off,
but of course any modulation will do,
and you would like to try
different modulations,
see what kinds of non-linearity there are.
So if there is serious non-linearity,
you may find that the Bell
inequalities is satisfied
very much faster or slower.
So this is all, well, okay, last slide.
It does seem to me that if
the world's always changing.
So when Gregor finished
his PhD, he went away.
That laboratory space,
that apparatus was gone
as soon as possible.
In comes a new student,
uses the same optical table,
and constructs their thing.
So anything longer than five
years is not gonna happen.
If you want 2,000 years of data,
well, you can't get
that even in cosmology.
So there's this interplay
between intervention
and measurement results.
It seems to be much more interactive.
The debugging process could
be described formally,
but we don't.
And I'm not saying we must,
but it does seem to me that one could say,
well, quantum mechanics is
not empirically adequate.
You cannot describe this decision
and game theoretic aspect
of what we're doing.
And the final thing,
measurement incompatibility
and Planck's constant
can be classical as well as quantum.
So this is just to say,
if you want to do causal
modeling absolutely classically,
so long as when it's necessary,
you put in a good Lorentz
invariant description of
with Planck's constant as
the amplitude of the noise,
then you can model everything classically.
Now, I'm not saying that anything of this,
this doesn't change quantum
computing at all, for example.
You have your apparatus, you
have Gregor's experiment.
He designs the experiment,
he puts it all together, he runs it.
The data doesn't care how I describe it.
If I use CM+ or quantum
electromagnetism, it doesn't matter.
What does matter is the theory guides
what you think is gonna be
an interesting experiment
to start to construct.
There's an element of of the human will
at the scale of design and
implementation of the apparatus.
There is no, none of my
will or Gregor Weihs's will
is involved at the 25 kilohertz,
no, 40 kilohertz scale, of
each individual event in there.
The reason those events happen
is because you have used
an avalanche photodiode,
which you deliberately used
because it exhibits events.
You do not use rocks.
Rocks are just, well, you know,
unless of course you have
some really sophisticated
data analysis out the out of the rock,
and you use a very specific kind of rock,
which is just as specific
as the materials you use
for the avalanche photodiode.
I'm 25 and a half minutes in.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much Peter.
Was very, very interesting.
Another fly in the ointment. (laughs)
- (laughs) No, no, taking a fly out.
- So any questions before
we open up the floor
for our closing?
David?
- Peter, thank you.
That was really interesting,
and I might've missed it,
so maybe I'm really collapsing
things much too far.
But for your last point
here about quantum noise
and its consequence being
modeled classically,
is that because what matters
to the dynamics of the classic,
of the object we already
chose to treat classically,
is 'cause those dynamics are sensitive
to things like two-point
functions of quantum fluctuations,
which we can then presumably, at least,
under many conditions, replace with
a corresponding classical object?
Or is that missing more of the structure
that you had in mind?
I'm wondering, this
last part in particular.
We do that all the time as a convenience
when trying to model things on,
admittedly, classical computers.
We'll initialize a simulation
by matching the statistics
of two-point correlation functions,
even though we're gonna then evolved them
perfectly classically,
but we think they had a, in some sense,
capturing a kind of quantum
mechanical boundary,
something like that.
Is there more than that, or
is that a reasonable analogy?
- There is.
- Okay.
- The way I think about,
this is, for one thing,
correlations at space-like separation,
you can consider classically
because the operators do commute.
At time-like separation,
they don't commute,
but we still have
correlations we need to model.
So the way we model that is use collapse.
But as far as the classical
physics is concerned,
it's just you use commuting
operators to model that.
So in the signal analysis sort
of framework, it's extremely,
it's really quite natural to do that.
But the analyticity I
mentioned on the second slide
is critical to whether you
want to use the mathematics
or quantum field theory or not,
because analyticity is
mathematically so beautiful.
You don't want to throw that away at all.
But on the other hand, if
you're doing signal analysis,
maybe the cost of having a
hundred million collapses
in the mathematics, you
know, just in the model,
might over overturn the
advantage of using analyticity.
- A quick follow up?
- Yeah.
- [David] For that, that was very helpful,
even just the gesture right,
and I wonder-
- It's not a Wick rotation.
- No, I won't even make the joke.
But for, have you already thought about
things like the Leggett-Garg inequality,
which as you may know is
a Bell-like inequality,
but for correlation of measurements
on a single system over time,
it sounds like that should,
might be a way to break
what otherwise looks like in isomorphism.
But you might have thought
about all that as well.
- I'm just gonna say to
you, but it's isomorphic,
so anything that quantum
quantum field theory can model,
can be modeled by a different model
or what looks like a different model.
But really, the isomorphism
is completely non-local
because it is a projection
to positive frequency.
And so it just, in some sense,
it puts you in still an
interpretive mess, as far as the,
but nonetheless, it's just an alternative.
It's a different way of looking at it.
And it's significantly different, I think.
And like I said on the first
slide in the pale gray,
this, I think, does give a
way to rethink renormalization
as well as rethink the measurement theory.
- [Priya] Thanks.
Chris, and then...
- Or just that you had this broader band,
oh you called it an artifact,
so I was just wondering,
you know that it's an artifact
or you assume it's an artifact?
- Well, I called it an artifact because,
partly because Gregor
didn't know it existed
before I pointed it out
to him 10 years ago.
But it's not clear to me what
the explanation for it is.
If I knew what the explanation was,
then I perhaps would be properly justified
calling it an artifact.
- [Audience Member] This is the only thing
I noticed from the talk.
- All right. (laughs)
- [Audience Member] But I
know that same chemistry,
you know, what's artifact for one
could be found 20 years by another.
"Oh, this is actually the real thing."
Most interesting part.
- Oh, it might be that this
indeed is completely new physics
and it will transform everything.
But it's more likely that
it's an artifact, yeah.
- [Priya] Chris.
- Yeah, so very curious,
I know you didn't have a chance
to go into a lot of the details,
but I was curious about exactly
what the isomorphic
structures are that you're,
so if they're both just Hilbert spaces,
there's one sense in
which it could be trivial,
but there might be more
structures on the Hilbert space
that you're mapping into in another.
And similar to Dave's question,
I was wondering just like,
you know, think of the
standard properties,
you think of the quantum vacuum,
like the Reeh-Schlieder theorem.
How is that modeled in CM+?
- What you can do is you,
if you construct the quantum field,
the electromagnetic quantum field theory
in terms of creation and
annihilation operators,
then there's an involution
that you can construct,
which allows you to construct in terms of
the same creation of
organization operators,
an operator that commutes everywhere.
So instead of the f measurement
and the g measurement,
the commutator being a
function of the f and g,
a linear function of the f and g,
instead of that, you
find that the commutator
of this new f measurement
and g measurement is zero.
So the involution does the job,
but the involution has
a time reversal in it.
And that's non-local.
So it's a very, very simple construction.
If I was giving an hour-long court talk,
then it would be in
there, and in one slide.
It's quite simple, but anyway.
- [Priya] did you have a quick follow up?
- [Chris] Well, so I
still don't understand
how like the entanglement
properties of the quantum vacuum
would be mapped into the
way you're describing
the quantum effects due
to the classical noise.
- Well, you now have this new mathematics,
and you will be free to interpret it
in whichever way you like.
Now, negative frequencies, of course,
could be interpreted as a retrocausality,
but on the other hand
it doesn't necessarily
have to be interpreted that way.
Just as those different
interpretations you can have
of the quantum mechanics mathematics,
you can have different
interpretations in this sort of way.
It's a free for all.
- [Priya] Okay, great.
Thank you so much, Peter.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- [Priya] Okay.